la situation énergétique en France et
inédite pour cet hiver pourquoi parce
que depuis trois décennies c'est la
première fois qu'on a autant de
centrales nucléaires qui sont en
maintenance
il y en a une vingtaine qui sont encore
maintenant ça se représente à peu près
40 % du parc nucléaire français et ce
qui se passe c'est que le nucléaire en
France représente 70 % de la production
d'électricité c'est à dire que la France
est le pays le plus nucléarisé au monde
donc quand vous avez sur le gros morceau
de la production c'est-à-dire le parc
nucléaire des problèmes de maintenance
de corrosion même si les Français
consomment moins d'électricité font
attention et que l'industrie consomme
moins aussi c'est tendu si on a même un
froid un peu modéré cet hiver il peut y
avoir des coupures localisées sur
certains départements en janvier ou en
février donc le problème est que la
production nucléaire tant qu'elle
redémarre pas qui a une tension sur le
système électrique français alors on
parle pas de blackout etc d'effondrement
général du système avec une panne
générale mais des coupures localisées
qui peuvent concerner principalement des
ménages alors c'est ça des ménages donc
on va pouvoir pour concrètement pour les
Français qui nous regardent est-ce qu'il
va y avoir des coupures d'électricité en
après-midi il peut y avoir pendant
l'heure de pointe des coupures qui sont
localisées qui vont durer maximum deux
heures pour ça parce que moi j'ai de la
viande au frais non mais c'est la
question qu'on se pose alors le réseau
de transport
des envoyer des alertes à J - 3 j moins
2 sur toute la viande alors la veille
Cyril vers 17h tu pourras rentrer ton
adresse sur l'application de RTE et voir
si tu es concerné par la coupure
si t'es concerné tu es comme un con tu
vas faire tu vas la mettre ou la viande
parce que moi je vais pas la bouffer
comme ça 25 steaks moi je mange pas de
viande en vrai tellement j'ai des
yaourts j'ai de la Danette tu vois des
conneries quoi j'ai du kiri quoi mais
c'est clair que sérieusement ça pose un
vrai problème bien sûr surtout de
manière très sérieuse pour ne pas
déconner mais sérieux par exemple sur
hospitalisés chez eux t'as raison
du gouvernement avec les préfets avec
les systèmes de de secours pour essayer
d'anticiper la situation et éviter que
ça pose des problèmes à des gens qui ont
vraiment besoin de l'électricité du
chauffage ou d'une alarme Raphaël ce que
tu ce que vous êtes en train de nous
dire c'est que et là c'est sûr on est
sûr on nous disait il y a quelques mois
il y aura jamais de coupure de courant
chez les particuliers aujourd'hui c'est
sûr ben moi je l'avais dit dès le 24
février
et je dis pas maintenant que c'est sûr
parce qu'il faut rester fort de la
différence dans la vie c'est
pratiquement
mais c'est une situation qui est sans
précédent qui est inédite donc ça va
dans la situation énergétique française
ça va arriver quand c'est le risque est
élevé et donc la situation est probable
mais alors moi je suis pas comme les
médecins bac + 12 bien sûr annonce leur
diplôme et qui disent des bêtises si
j'ai aussi un doctorat
il a raison donc
Eric non pas Eric parce que Eric c'est
après Raphaël aujourd'hui il y a combien
de pourcentage de chance qui est plus et
qui est des coupures comme ça dans le
pourcentage ce serait idiot de le donner
mais si il fait froid en journée février
il y a un ménage mais ce sera pas sur
tout un département ce sera localisé et
tournant et si on t'appelle quand on te
dit la veille on te dit demain on va te
couper ton à 3 jours on te l'envoie une
alerte à 2 jours on te la confirme et la
veille on te dit si tu es concerné ou
pas ça veut dire comment tu dois
t'organiser non mais je sais mais bon
moi c'est pas moi qui suis RTE à une
édition pourquoi il y a eu des grèves
en octobre chez EDF qui ont retardé la
maintenance c'était la réparation des
centrales donc c'était probablement des
grèves fondées moi je suis pas là pour
dire c'était une bonne ou une mauvaise
idée mais ça du retard sur la réparation
des centrales qui sont en maintenance
centrale nucléaire
aujourd'hui c'est des décisions
politiques qui ont nous ont fait être
dans une situation
alors j'ai bien dit au début que je
n'accuse je suis pas là pour prendre
position là dessus
on se pose la question parce que ça y
est là les Français seront-ils privés
d'électricité cet hiver Raphaël bourouma
professeur d'économie spécialiste de
l'énergie nous dit qu'il y a de fortes
chances oui pour certains foyers voilà
on va être obligé combien d'heures par
jour maximum deux heures et qu'une seule
fois c'est-à-dire personne sera
concernée plusieurs fois donc ça veut
dire énorme c'est déjà terrible ah bien
sûr ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire par
exemple voilà on va une fois qu'on l'a
fait une fois ça sera un autre gars quoi
c'est ce qui disent qu'il faut que ce
soit ciblés tournant que ça concerne
tout le pays c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
parce qu'un département consomra
beaucoup d'électricité plus qu'un autre
et c'est le risque sera plus important
pour ce département là donc c'est
n'importe qui quoi c'est la tête du
client non alors ça concerne plutôt 60%
des de des foyers parce que il
parce que voilà mais je lis pas dans
l'avenir non plus je suis pas Madame
Soleil c'est de fortes chances et Eric
brocardi porte-parole des
sapeurs-pompiers de France quelle serait
les risques si les français étaient
privés d'accès au numéro d'urgence le
risque évidemment on le connaitre pas
forcément les joindre mais là
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez dit ce qui
a été évoqué à l'instant il y a deux
trois mots clés qui sont extrêmement
importants c'est les probabilités en
fait et la mise en préparation à un
événement pour pas que ça devienne une
crise le document qui est sorti au
niveau du gouvernement c'est pour bien
expliquer ce que l'on a reçu dans les
centres de secours pour l'intermédiaire
des préfectures c'est effectivement un
document de préparation c'est-à-dire
qu'en gros sur les 9 pages il y a deux
pages qui concernent un déjà la mise en
veille et deuxième point surtout c'est
cette préparation en cas de coupure ou
autre donc aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation où nous les sapeurs-pompiers
on est par activité préparer à tout type
d'événements et à ce genre de situation
lorsque les appels sont reçus dans les
centres d'appel il y a la 16 millions
pendant l'année sur ces 16 millions
pendant l'année qui sont reçus dans les
centres d'appel déjà il y en a 7% qui
sont injustifiés donc déjà si on
consommait moins du sapeur-pompier pour
délester un peu la charge sur les lignes
des secours c'est déjà un point
important de ce côté là le deuxième
sujet c'est au regard effectivement de
la projection et il a évoqué tout à
l'heure un petit moment donné c'est que
il y a un feu rouge un feu orange et un
feu vert qui ont été
particulièrement caractérisés dans cette
note et qui dénote qu'à un moment donné
il va falloir prendre des mesures prises
par les préfets qui ont déjà qui sont
déjà dans un mode de préparatoire quand
on dit préparatoire c'est de localiser
les structures les plus dépendantes en
matière énergétique et nous les
sapeurs-pompiers on est déjà en mode ou
par construction des choses on est déjà
en autarcie si demain on a par exemple
deux ou trois heures de coupure qui
arrive sur un centre de réception des
appels ce qui me fait rappeler aussi une
situation que l'on connaît c'est que par
exemple la tempête Alex dans le 06
personne s'est demandé à un moment donné
comment les sapeurs-pompiers qui étaient
isolés à Saint-Martin-Vésubie on fait
pour être connecté avec le reste de
l'état-major donc ça veut dire même en
situation
ultra périlleuse nous sommes dans la
mesure et dans la posture de pouvoir
nous adapter et ça c'est un élément
qu'on doit faire valoir parce que chez
les sapeurs-pompiers il y a les
personnes que vous voyez dans les
ambulances mais il y a aussi beaucoup de
petites mains derrière qui sont là pour
générer et de continuer à préserver le
système de télécommunication pour ce qui
est du on va dire tout simplement du du
celui qui va vouloir l'utiliser un
d'être extrêmement vigilant sur la
manière dont il va appeler les secours
est-ce que c'est utile ou non est-ce
qu'on a vraiment besoin nécessaire et on
rappelle aussi une chose c'est que dans
l'utilisation du téléphone portable que
vous ayez ou non une puce le 112 quand
vous le faites il borne sur le relais le
plus proche même si sur votre téléphone
il n'y a rien marqué au niveau du réseau
et ça c'est une information importante
parce que beaucoup de monde l'ignorent
et aujourd'hui vous utilisez sans doute
sans le savoir il y a des déclencheurs
automatique SOS dans les voitures quand
vous faites malheureux pocket call dans
votre poche qui déclenche le secours
fatalité des fois on vous appelle vous
êtes dans la poche et vous nous entendez
pas en disant
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il y a d'autres sources de production
d'électricité en France il y a des
barrages hydrauliques il y a de l'éolien
il y a du solaire mais qu'on a été
obligé de rouvrir une centrale à charbon
ce qui pollue énormément parce que il y
a un problème de maintenance sur le
nucléaire donc il y a effectivement un
défaut d'anticipation de la politique
énergétique française et ça n'a rien à
voir avec la guerre en Ukraine d'accord
merci de dire Eric je voulais simplement
rajouter une chose c'est qu'on est
encore face à une situation on doit
éduquer le citoyen face à des risques et
là on anticipe un risque au black-out on
était dans cette année-là on a
effectivement eu la crise sanitaire donc
on était préparé on a eu effectivement
une situation là aujourd'hui où
structurellement on va se retrouver
confronté à des difficultés difficultés
pardon au niveau de la charge
énergétique donc évidemment c'est encore
une attitude ou le citoyen doit se
comporter se conformer malheureusement à
ce qu'on va lui demander de faire mais
ce sont des petits gestes au quotidien
qui pour éviter la rupture on va dire et
ben on va éviter on va regarder d'un peu
plus près les factures quelque part